the area surrounding the North Pole may
seem like a frozen and desolate
environment where nothing ever changes
but it is actually a complex and finely
balanced natural system and its extreme
location makes it vulnerable to feedback
processes that can magnify even tiny
changes in the atmosphere in fact
scientists often describe the Arctic as
the canary in the coalmine when it comes
to predicting the impact of climate
change one major type of climate
feedback involves reflectivity white
surfaces like snow and ice are very
effective at reflecting the sun's energy
back into space while darker land and
water surfaces absorb much more incoming
sunlight when the Arctic warms just a
little some of the snow and ice melts
exposing the ground and ocean underneath
the increased heat absorbed by these
surfaces causes even more melting and so
on and although the current situation in
the Arctic follows the warming pattern
the opposite is also possible a small
drop in temperatures would cause more
freezing increasing the amount of
reflective snow and ice this would
result in less sunlight being absorbed
and lead to a cycle of cooling as in
previous ice ages Arctic sea ice is also
responsible for another feedback
mechanism through insulation by forming
a layer on the ocean surface the ice
acts as a buffer between the frigid
arctic air and the relatively warmer
water underneath but when it fins breaks
or melts in any spot heat escapes from
the ocean warming the atmosphere and
causing more ice to melt in turn both of
these are examples of positive feedback
loops not because they do something good
but because the initial change is
amplified in the same direction a
negative feedback loop on the other hand
is when the initial change leads to
effects that work in the opposite
direction
melting ice also causes a type of
negative feedback by releasing moisture
into the atmosphere this increases the
amount and thickness of clouds present
which can cool the atmosphere by
blocking more sunlight but this negative
feedback loop is short-lived due to the
brief Arctic
for the rest of the year when sunlight
is scarce the increased moisture and
clouds actually warm the surface by
trapping the Earth's heat turning the
feedback loop positive for all but a
couple of months while negative feedback
loops encourage stability by pushing a
system towards equilibrium positive
feedback loops destabilize it by
enabling larger and larger deviations
and the recently increased impact of
positive feedbacks may have consequences
far beyond the Arctic on a warming
planet these feedbacks ensure that the
North Pole warms at a faster rate than
the equator the reduced temperature
differences between the two regions may
lead to slower jet stream winds and less
linear atmospheric circulation in the
middle latitudes where most of the
world's population lives many scientists
are concerned that shifts in weather
patterns will last longer and be more
extreme with short-term fluctuations
becoming persistent cold snaps heat
waves droughts and floods so the Arctic
sensitivity doesn't just serve as an
early warning alarm for climate change
for the rest of the planet its feedback
loops can affect us in much more direct
and immediate ways as climate scientists
often warn what happens in the Arctic
doesn't always stay in the Arctic